One of the most confusing things for a lot of people about the parameter, this
is how it will get bound within functions when they get passed as call backs.
Consider this example where we pass our function to setTimeout,
which will call the function for us a second later.
As you can see, we aren't providing any values that could be
passed as arguments to our call back function fn.
So it seems hard to imagine that this code will work as we want it to.
Let's focus on those positional parameters first,
since they seem a bit more intuitive.
What do you expect they're going to be bound to?
Hint.
Remember that you can't tell what value a function's parameter will be bound to,
until you look at the specific indication of that function.
So we'll need to go looking for the indication of the fn function.
Take a moment to write out your answer